U.S senator Bob Menendez stayed silent
as he arrived at federal court on
Wednesday
his wife Nadine pleaded not guilty to a
range of corruption charges including
passing secrets to Egypt
the judge set his bail at one hundred
thousand dollars a day earlier one of
his co-defendants Egyptian American
businessman wahil Hana also pleaded not
guilty the senator and his wife accepted
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
bribes in exchange for Senator Menendez
using his power and influence to protect
and to enrich those businessmen
and to benefit the government of Egypt
prosecutors alleged that Menendez gave
secrets to the Egyptian government
including passing along the names of the
local employees of the U.S Embassy in
Cairo and that his wife received a
Mercedes-Benz after Menendez pressured
officials in New Jersey to quash an
investigation into a businessman here
you can see just a fraction of the cash
investigators searching his house found
hundreds of thousands of dollars in cash
and 13 gold bars while the senator did
not make any comments as he left court
earlier in the week he made a defiant
statement defending himself against all
of the allegations in including that he
was bribed by Egypt I have always worked
to hold accountable those countries
including Egypt for human rights abuses
the repression of its citizenry civil
society and more
those who now are attempting to malign
my actions as it relates to Egypt simply
don't know the facts dozens of his
fellow members of Congress including
from his own party have called on
Menendez to resign look I've known
Senator Menendez a very long time and it
was truly truly upsetting
but we all know
that senators
four Senators there's a much much higher
standard and clearly when you read the
indictment Center Menendez fell way way
below that standard
and the investigation is not over the
FBI is reportedly probing whether
Egyptian intelligence Services played
any role in the alleged bribery scheme
Gabriel ozando Al Jazeera New York
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera